اعتبر نوري المالكي نائب الرئيس العراقي
ان ما دعاه تحرير حلب من الارهاب سيقود
الى تحرير سوريا وفي تصريحات بالعاصمه
الايرانيه طهران اضاف ان الجيش العراقي
والحشد الشعبي قد يتوجهان الى سوريا لقتال
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وجبهه النصره اذا
طلب السوريون ذلك بعد الانتهاء من استعاده
الموصل
السلام عليكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش
فيما وراءه الى من يوجه نوري المالكي
رسائله من طهران بخصوص الدور المحتمل
للحشد الشعبي والجيش العراقي في سوريا
وكيف تقرا القوى العراقيه خاصه في التحالف
الشيعي ابعاد واهداف وتوقيت زياره المالك
لطهران
هم النظام السوري حضر بقوه في اجتماعات
نور المالكي نائب الرئيس العراقي مع
المسؤولين الايرانيين الذين التقاهم علي
شمخاني الامين العام لمجلس الامن القومي
وعلي لاريجاني رئيس البرلمان وعلي ولايه
مستشار مرشد الجمهوريه وهذا الاخير تحديدا
اكد على موقف طهران الداعم لما وصفه
بالمقاومه التي تنطلق من ايران وتمر
بالعراق وصولا الى سوريا ولبنان وفلسطين
وقد شاركهم المالكي موقفهم هذا بعد ما
استمع الى اشادات بدوره في حكم العراق
واشار الى استعداد الجيش العراقي والحشد
للتوجه الى سوريا لمحاربه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه والنصره بعد استعاده الموصل لكن
ما هو السياق العراقي لزياره المالك
لطهران تقرير فتح
اسماعيل تشتد متاعب نور المالك في العراق
ويتعاظم احباطه فلا يستسلم يلجا الى ايران
فتحت به كاشد ما يكون الاحتفاء اما هو
فيسارع الى استثمار زيارته من اجل استعاده
حضور سياسي بائد في سبيل ذلك ومتطوع على
ما يبدو يخض المالك فيما يحلو لطهران
الخوض فيه هذه الايام يشيد بما سماها
انتصارات حلب ويهاجم السعوديه لكنه يتجاوز
الانطباع والتوصيف الى ما هو اكثر واخطر
يعلن ان الجيش العراقي والحشد الشعبي قد
يتوجهان الى سوريا من اجل تصفيه الحساب مع
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وجبهه النصره انما
ليس قبل حسم معركه الموصل سبق لمثل هذه
الدعوات باجتياز الحدود ان رددها قاده
ميليشيات اخرون في العراق لكن واذ ترد هذه
المره من طهران وعلى لسان المالك القيادي
في حزب الدعوه الحاكم ونائب رئيس
الجمهوريه فان الامر يرقى ربما الى
اعتباره
رساله فهل هي رساله المالك شخصيا علما ان
صفته الدستوريه لا تؤه ه لذلك ام هي رساله
ايران تسوقها بلسان المالك السياق العام
لا ينفي تلك الفرضيه فايران تروج هذه
الايام لانها الاحق بالنفوذ في سوريا
وحدها دون غيرها بينما يردد عسكرييها
ومدنها تلميحا وتصريحا احاديث عن بقاء
طويل في الشام وكما اثبتت السنوات الماضيه
فان النفوذ والهيمنه يمكن ان يتحققا لا
قوى ايرانيه وحسب وانما ايضا باذرع تدور
في فلك ايران كما فعلت الميليشيات الشيعيه
من باكستان وافغانستان والعراق ولبنان
وغيرها بهذا المعنى تبدو رساله المالك
اقليميه والى اكثر من طرف ربما وهي تتقاطع
مع تصريحات مسؤولين ايرانيين كمستشار
المرشد علي اكبر ولايه الذي دافع عن
استمرار وجود حزب الله في سوريا حتى بعد
انتهاء النزم
او علي شمخاني الذي اعتبر ان محادثات
استان المزمع ستكون على اساس الاعتراف
بحكم نظام الاسد وهذان المسؤولان تحديدا
اشدا بنور المالك ودوره في المشهد العراقي
وايضا بالحشد الشعبي ودوره في المعادلات
الامنيه المحليه
والاقليميه تتكرر محاولات المالك اذا
للعوده الى الواجهه السياسيه من البوابه
الايرانيه بعد اخفاقه في تح ذلك بنفسه اذ
قبل بمظاهرات خلال زياراته مناطق في جنوب
العراق يفترض انها حواضن شعبيه لحزبه في
بعض تلك المناطق داس العراقيون على صوره
متهمين اياه بانه راس الفساد ومحمل منه
كثيرا مما حل بالعراق من مصائب امنيه
ومعيش وسياسيه وبعته لايران ولا يبدو
الرجل منبوذا في الاوساط الشعبيه وحسب بل
ايضا من جانب قوى شيعيه عده لا بل وداخل
حزبه حزب الدعوه اذ ينظر اليه باعتباره
عنصر توتر وعامل فرقه يعيق وحده الحزب
ويعرقل تقاربه مع قوى اخرى مهمه كالتي
الصدري الذي قال زعيمه مقتدى الصدر ان
المالك مريض بحب
السلطه نرحب بضيفنا في هذه حلقه من بغداد
عدنان السراج رئيس المركز العراقي للتنميه
الاعلاميه وعضو ائتلاف دوله القانون ومن
عمان دكتور يحيى الكبيسي مستشار المركز
العراقي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه نبدا
بالسيد عدنان السراج في في بغداد هذا
الكلام الذي قاله السيد نوري المالكي في
في طهران برايك لمن هو موجه
بالذات نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه
لك ولضيفك العزيز ولمشاهده الكرام اهلا
وسهلا انا اعتقد اليوم السيد الوري
المالكي يمثل نائب رئيس الجمهوريه وهو
الامين العام لحزب الدعوه الاسلاميه وايضا
في نفس الوقت هو بالنسبه له رئيس تحالف
ائتلاف دوله القانون او كتله ائتلاف دوله
القانون وبالتالي هذه الصفات السياسيه
والمناصب الحكوميه تعطيه الحق في ان يتكلم
او يعطي رايه وما اعطاه في طهران هو يمثل
رايه الشخصي وهو قالها في المؤتمر الصحفي
بان هذا الراي الذي يتكلم عنه هو راي شخصي
ولكن هذا الراي الشخصي يلقى قبولا واسعا
في بغداد من ناحيه الراي العام ومن ناحيه
الحكومه ومن ناحيه الجيش وحتى من ناحيه
دول العالم الساند العراق يعتقدون بان
سوريا ما يحصل فيها يؤثر تاثيرا سلبا او
ايجابا باتجاه العراق وان مساله طرد داعش
من العراق لا تكتمل الا بطرد داعش من
سوريا وخصوصا الحدود المتاخمه للعراق بمدي
النيا من القامشلي وصولا الى الرطبه
والقائم فلذلك انا اعتقد الر عن السيد
المالكي هو تعبير يكاد يكون من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه امرا حتميا او مقبولا دول
العالم تقول ذلك حتى امريكا تقول ذلك وحتى
العراق طلب من امريكا تامين الحدود مع
سوريا بضربات جويه او بفرق مجوقل لان
العراق لا يملك عمليات انزال مجوقل في
مسائل تتعلق بضبط الحدود السوريه العراقيه
حتى بعد الانتها داعش اسمح اس اسمح لي فقط
سيد يعني لو سمحت لي ارجو ان تك ارجو ان
تكون تستمع الي ارجو ان تكو كونها تصريحات
شخصيه وليس لها اي تاثير رسمي ولكن على
المستوى العام والاستراتيجي اعتقد لها صد
ولها امكانيات التطبيق في حاله طرد داعش
من الموصل ارجو ان تكون تستمع الي حتى
يكون هناك اخذ وعطاء بيننا وليس حديثا من
في في اتجاه واحد نقطتان لو سمحت لي
النقطه الاولى انه مسؤول ب فيذا الحجم
يعبر عن راي شخصي هذا عموما في السياسه لا
يوجد شيء اسمه راي شخصي عندما تتحدث انت
تتحدث بالصفات التي ذكرتها النقطه
الثانيه قلت بان ما قاله
هو يلقى صدا كيف يلقى صدا والكل الان يبحث
عن تسويه سياسيه في سوريا وعن خروج من
فيها وليس دخول
اخرين اذا اذا اذا واضح ان سيد السراج لا
يسمعني
اذا الملاحظه التي ذكرتها السيد يحيى
الكبيسي هل لديك اي تعليق
بشانها يعني بدايه مساء الخير الك ولضيفك
الكريم ولمشاهده قناه الجزيره يعني اولا
بالتاكيد لا وجود لشيء اسمه تصريح شخصي
يعني في النهايه السيد المالكي يعبر عن
اراء يعني تعامل معها بشكل عملي عندما كان
رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء يعني السيد المالكي
هو من وضع العراق جزءا من الاستقطاب في
المنطقه السيد المالكي هو الذي سمح بذهاب
الميليشيات التي اعاد انتاجها في منتصف
عام 2012 الى سوريا للقتال في سوريا بغطاء
رسمي من الحكومه العراقيه وبالتالي السييد
المالكي في طهران يعبر عن موقفه السياسي
وليس عن موقفه الشخصي هذا اولا ولكن اذا
ما حاولنا تحليل ما قاله انا اعتقد يجب ان
نحلل ما قاله في سياقين مختلفين في اطار
في السياق السياسي هو ما زال مصرا على ان
يكون العراق جزءا من سياسه الخنادق في
المنطقه يعني هو مصر على ان يكون العراق
جزءا من الخندق الايراني في اطار صراع
الخنادق الموجود في المنطقه حاليا يعني
ايران العراق سوريا حزب الله في لبنان
ومظلته ربما المطلوبه والمرغوب فيها هي
روسيا لكن من الناحيه العسكريه الكلام
الذي قال به السيد المالكي لا معنى له
يعني اولا ال ل الجيش العراقي ولا
الميليشيات العراقيه لديها قدره حقيقيه
على ان تكون
عاملا يعني حقيقيا في الصراع في سوريا
يعني اولا تنظيم داعش ما زال تنظيما قويا
داخل العراق وهو حتى ان يعني هزم في
الموصل فهو سيبقى خطرا يعني يستنزف القوات
العسكريه العراقيه والم وميليشيا الحشد
الشعبي لسنوات قادمه وليست هناك امكانيه
حقيقيه من الناحيه العسكريه لذهاب للجيش
العراقي ولا هذه الميليشيات للقتال في
سوريا ولو عدنا الى السياق التاريخي
سنكتشف انه الميليشيات العراقيه التي
قاتلت في سوريا هي بضعه مئات على اقصى
تقدير هي ربما بحدود 2000 الى 3000 مقاتل
لم يكن لهم تاثير حقيقي في يعني على
علاقات القوه في هذا الصراع ولكن كانت
هناك رغبه من من الفاعل السياسي الشيعي ل
يعني يكون العراق جزءا من سياسه الاستقطاب
في المنطقه من خلال ارسال هذه الميليشيات
نعم ما فهم من كلام نوري المالكي سيد
عدنان السراج كانه اراد ان يقول في طهران
انا رجلكم الاول انا افضل من من حيدر
العبادي وانا قادر على التماهي معكم بشكل
افضل لان السيد العبادي حاول قدر الامكان
ان يقول بان الميليشيات العراقيه الموجوده
في سوريا هي ذه من تلقائ نفسها ولا تلزمنا
في شيء هل يمكن اعتبار مثل هذا الكلام
صحيح لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد اليوم ايران
قالتها بشكل واضح حتى في سوريا قالت لا
روسيا ولا ايران تسعى الى النفوذ انما
الشعب السوري هو الذي يقرر ذلك اعتقد
اليوم ايران تدعم السيد العبادي بشكل واضح
وهي تدعمه بنفس الطريقه التي دعمت بها
السيد المالكي هي تدعم الجيش وتدعم الطاقه
والق قود والعلاقات جيده والعبادي لاكثر
من مره قال نحن يعني نعيش مع ايران سياسه
البلد الافضل وبالتالي هناك علاقات متميزه
مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه هكذا
يقول العبادي وهكذا تقول ايران فذلك ايران
لن تعادي السيد العبادي على عكس من ذلك هي
التي سعت الى تثبيته من خلال الضغط على
الكتل الشيعيه خصوصا في التظاهرات الاخيره
للتيار الصدري وهذا معروف هي التي مارست
دورا مهما ورئيسيا في تهدئه الاجواء
الشيعيه بين قوسين لو كنا نريد ان نقول
ذلك وايضا في نفس الوقت هي التي لجمت
السيد المالكي في مساله المشاكل التي حصلت
بينه وبين السيد العبادي في بدايه ترشيح
السيد العبادي هذا المصف فايران لا يهمها
ان يكون السيد المالكي ورجل الاول ولا
العبادي والرجل الاول ايران تسعى الى
سياسه المحاور كما قال السيد ال كويسي كما
العراق وهذا امر محتوم في السياسه والا
لما ذهبت تركيا الى روسيا وتشكل م محورا
من اجل طرد داعش من سوريا او تهديه
الاجواء في سوريا بالحل السلمي هذا امر
محتوم العراق سيتجه شم ابينا الى سياسه
المحاور بعد طرد داعش من الموصل وهذه حكم
سنه الحياه اعتقد اليوم تركيا انضمت الى
محور روسيا ايران واعتقد ايران العراق
سينضم الى هذا المحور في حاله اذا بقيت
النصره وداعش قويه في سوريا ولكن ايضا
هناك بالتاكيد قراءه للقوى السياسيه
العراقيه خاصه في التحالف الشيعي لابعاد
واهداف وتوقيت هذه الزياره للمالك في الى
طهران لنا
عوده
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد ودلالات
تصريحات نوري المالكي في طهران عن استعداد
الجيش العراقي والحشد الشعبي لمحاربه جبهه
النصره وتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في سوريا
بعد الانتهاء من استعاده الموصل سيد
الكبيسي هل هل تعتقد بان القوى السياسيه
في العراق واساسا التحالف الشيعي سينظرون
الى ما لقيه المالكي من حفاوه ومن اشاده
وتصريحاته هناك وكان الرجل يلقى تزكيه من
طهران تعطيه الافضليه على بقيه اقرانه
داخل الساحه
العراقيه يعني الحقيقه هذا الموضوع موضوع
معقد ومركب وليس من السهل شرحه يعني فيما
يتعلق بالموقف من سوريا لا هناك اجماع لدى
الفاعلين السياسيين الشيعه في العراق على
على هذا الموقف يعني موقف السيد المالكي
لا يختلف عن اي موقف لاي فاعل سياسي شيعي
داخل العراق هم يعتقدون انه الصراع في
سوريا يؤثر تماما على وضعهم داخل العراق
وبالتالي هم يعني مجمعون على ضروره ان
يكونوا داعمين لنظام بشار الاسد ضد خصومه
يعني هذا موقف حاسم وهو ليس موقف عراقي
كما اقول يعني هناك انقسام عراقي شديد حول
الموقف من سوريا لكن الفاعل السياسي
الشيعي موقفه موحد تجاه قضيه سوريا لكن
ايضا هناك اختلاف في في طبيعه الصراع
الشيعي الشيعي داخل العراق بمعنى انه نعم
ايران في لحظه ما وجدت انه السيد المالكي
هو رجلها الاقوى داخل العراق ولكنها في
النهايه لم تستطع ان تثبته يعني طبيعه
ديناميكيات الصراع الشيعي داخل العراق
فرضت وضع العبادي على الرغم من الاراده
الايرانيه المعلنه في حينها لان يعود
السيد المالكي لولايه ثالثه وبالتالي لا
لا تملك ايران القول الفصل في اداره
الصراع الشيعي الشيعي داخل العراق يعني
السيد السستاني له موقف مؤثر الاطراف
العقلانيه الشيعيه تحديدا السيد مقتضى
الصدر والى حد ما السيد عمار الحكيم سبق
لهم ان تمردوا اكثر من مره على الاراده
الايرانيه وبالتالي هناك انقسام شيعي شيعي
اليوم بين يمين شيعي متطرف يقوده السيد
المالكي وتمثله المليشيات بشكل اساسي وبين
عقلانيه شيعيه يعني دعمها السيد السيستاني
في لحظه ما لكنها الحقيقه اليوم في وضع
مربك جدا خاصه في اطار عدم وجود علاقات
جيده بين السيد مقتضى الصدر والسيد عمار
الحكيم من جهه ثانيه وبالتالي نحن امام
صراع حقيقي يعني حتى داخل حزب الدعوه او
ائتلاف دوله القانون يعني نحن ايضا صراع
ما بين تيار السيد المالكي من جهه وبين
تيار السيد العبادي من جهه ثانيه وبالتالي
نحن سنبقى في اطار هذا الصراع ودور ايران
هنا هي اداره العمليه يعني ايران ولكن
ايران ولكن ايران في فتره من الفترات سيد
الكبيسي ايران في فتره من الفترات كانت
الى جانب الولايات المتحده مؤيده لنوري
المالكي ونوري المالكي
لسنوات سيد سراج لسنوات نوري المالكي كان
كان يعتبر معادله امريكيه ايرانيه الان
كان طهران تريد اعاده تسويق المالكي من
جديد هل يمكن ان يفهم البقيه في العراق
مثل هذا
الامر لا ليس سهلا يعني اعتقد المالكي هو
حتى في المؤتمر الصحفي عندما سئل عن رغبته
بتجديد راسه او ترشيحه لراسه الوزراء قال
سوف لا ارشح في الدوره القادمه لاسباب لعل
بعضها قانوني يعني المجلس
النواب حدد دورتين لرئيس الوزراء ولكن هو
افصح عن رايه بانه لا يريد الترشيح الى
رئيس الوزراء اعتقد الايران اليوم اذا
ارادت ان تحتوي السيد المالكي بعناوين
الصداقه فهي تحتوي بعناوين اخرى مع اصدقاء
اخرى ولكن البيرو غندا اللي رافقت زياره
السيد المالكي ومجموعه الاعلاميين
المرافقين له وقابليه يعني تسويقه بهذه
الطريقه وصفت الامر على ان المالكي هو
الرجل المفضل نعم قد يكون الايرانيون
يشكرون السيد المالكي على سياسته في حسن
الجوار او التعامل مع المصالح العراقيه
والايرانيه بشكل متساوي ولكنهم في نفس
الوقت يستقبلون السيد عمار الحكيم والسيد
مقتضى الصدر والسيد عبادي بنفس الطريقه
وبنفس الاسلوب ولعله باكثر حفاوه ولكن
الترافق الاعلامي مع هذه الزياره وايضا
فوبيا المالكي لجهات معاديه له عمقت هذه
الزياره وجعلت الزياره كانما هي في المقام
الاول ولكن اعتقد اليوم ايران ليس في شغل
شاغل لتثبيت المالكي ايران في شغل شاغل
لتثبيت المحاور في المنطقه لانها تعتقد ان
الوضع في سوريا والوضع في العراق يتاثر
تتاثر المصالح العليا لايران تاثيرا كاملا
حول وجود التحالفات الدوليه حتى بوجود
روسيا يعني كما تعلم ايران لديها ايضا
ملاحظات على الوجود الروسي في سوريا فلذلك
هي تريد اعاده صياغه الاستراتيجيات
الاقليميه بما يضمن مصالحها العليا وهذا
يعني ان العراق يجب ان يكون ايضا امنا
ومستقرا وفي نفس الوقت يجب ان يكون ضمن
سياقات طرد داعش والنصره من العراق
والخروج من المحاور الدوليه وخصوصا
الروسيه والامريكيه نعم على ذكر المحاور
هناك مفرده محور المقاومه سيد الكتور
الكبيسي عادت مره اخرى في زياره المالكي
قالها هو قالها المسؤولون الايرانيون محور
المقاومه على اساس ايران العراق سوريا
لبنان هل تعتقد بان اعاده بث الروح في في
هذه المفرده التي غابت في السنوات الماضيه
بحكم خلط الاوراق الكبير في المنطقه هل
تعتقد بانها يمكن ان تلقى رواج وتسوق داخل
الصف الشيعي في العراق بهذا الشكل
لا هي هناك محاوله لاستخدام هذا الشعار
وترويجه
لاغراض متعلقه بطبيعه الاستقطاب في
المنطقه المقاومه اليوم لم تعد مرتبطه
باسرائيل المقاومه اليوم في ظل خلط
الاوراق كما وصفته يعني مرتبطه بعوامل
اخرى مرتبطه ايضا بالصراع الطائفي في
المنطقه وبالتالي نعم يعني هذا هذا الشعار
الذي استخدم كثيرا يعني لا معنى له في
الحقيقه سوى كيفيه او اليه استخدامه
لضمان محور يعني تتحكم به ايران في
المنطقه وقادر على يعني قادره ايران على
استخدامها لاغراض متعلقه بمصالحها العليا
سواء فيما يتعلق ب يعني ملفها النووي او
فيما يتعلق بنفوذها في المنطقه شكرا لك
دكتور يحيى الكبيسي مستشار المركز العراقي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من بغداد عدنان السراج رئيس المركز
العراقي للتنميه العالميه وعضو ائتلاف
القانون بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء خب غدا باذن الله قراءه جديده فيما
وراء خبر جديد استودعكم
الله